bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
en direct sur public sat vous allez
pouvoir suivre dans quelques instants
tout de suite même le début de la
discussion au Sénat autour du projet loi
de finances rectificatif pour
2013 c'est dans ce texte notamment que
son contenu les mesures d'allèigement
fiscaux et sociaux concernant le pacte
de responsabilité c'est également dans
le cadre de ce projet loi de finance
rectificative pour 2013 qui a été adopté
la semaine dernière à l'Assemblée
nationale un amendement socialiste qui
augmente la taxe de séjour dans les
hôtels de plus de trois étoiles
amendement socialiste de l'Assemblée
nationale qui sera peut-être en tout cas
annulé ici au Sénat ou alors un
compromis pourrait être trouvé avec le
gouvernement autour d'une application de
ce dispositif concernant la taxe de
séjour à partir du 1er janvier 2015 donc
tout de suite direct étion l'hémicycle
du Sénat a noté que cette séance sera
interrompue aux alentours de 16h30 17h
poursivre en direct sur notre antenne le
discours de François Hollande en direct
du Conseil économique social et
environnemental François Hollande qui va
introduire ouvrir la conférence sociale
qui se tient pendant 2 jours à Paris
donc discours à suivre en direct sur
notre antenne aux alentours de 16h30 17h
mais tout de suite direction l'hémicycle
du Sénat ce déficit budgétaire sera de
71,9 milliards d'euros en 2014 en
diminution de 2,9 milliards d'euros par
rapport à l'exécution
2013 comme le rappelle l'article
liminaire le déficit public atteindrait
3,8 points en baisse continue depuis
2012 le déficit structurel serait lui de
2,3 % du PIB son plus bas niveau depuis
2001 pour maintenir cette orientation le
gouvernement a annoncé lors de la
présentation du programme de stabilité
en avril dernier la réalisation de 4
milliards d'euros d'économie
supplémentaire dès l'exercice
2014 ces réductions de dépenses en cours
de gestion sont une première réponse à
la procédure de correction des écarts
qui a été enclenché à la suite du dépôt
du projet de loi de règlement pour
2013 le gouvernement aurait pu se
contenter de respecter à la lettre la
loi organique du 17 décembre 2012 et
attendre jusqu'au projet de loi de
finances 2015 pour proposer des mesures
de
correction nous vous proposons avec ce
projet de loi de finance
rectificative de ne pas attendre pour
corriger des écarts constatés en 2013 et
d'adopter dès maintenant des premières
mesures de
correction les 4 milliards d'euros
d'économie supplémentaire concernne
toutes les
administrations sauf les collectivités
territoriales qui elles prendront leur
part dans les économies prévues dans les
3 ans à
venir projet de loi de finance
rectificative prévoit ainsi 1,6
milliards d'euros d'annulation de crédit
sur le budget de l'État j'y reviendrai
dans un
instant le PLFR SS prévoit une économie
de 1,1 milliards d'euros sur les régimes
obligatoires de base notamment à travers
une mesure de gel des retraites qui
dépasse 1200 €
mensuels enfin un autre ensemble
d'économie ne nécessite pas de
traduction
législative il en va ainsi des moindres
dépenses du Fond national d'action
sociale financé par la branche famille
de la sécurité sociale d'une part et de
l'Unedic d'autre part constaté en fin
d'année
2013 ces moindres dépenses sont
pérennisées en 2014 pour un montant de 0
9 milliards d'euros au total dont 0,6
milliards sur
l'Unedic enfin les décaissements au
titre du programme d'investissement
d'avenir sont moins importants que prévu
pour 400 milliards millions d'euros ces
moindres dépenses sont une bonne
nouvelle non pas tant par leur impact
budgétaire qui est finalement assez
limité mais pour qu' pour ce qu'elle
révèle de l'action du
CGI le Commissariat général à
l'investissement qui qui ne se précipite
pas dans la sélection des projets qu'il
finance et qui prend le temps nécessaire
pour retenir les projets les plus
prometteurs c'est une garantie de bonne
gestion pour des investissements qui
mobiliseront les doners publqus sur
plusieurs
années je reviens sur les annulations
proposé par le
PLFR annulé pour 1,6 milliard d'euros en
cours de gestion dont 1 milliard d'euros
de crédit frais c'est-à-dire au-delà de
la réserve de précaution cela a été
rarement vu dans notre histoire
budgétaire c'est peut-être même sans
précédent c'est l'illustration de notre
volonté qui porte ses fruit de tenir la
dépense et d'engager sans tarder des
économies vous avez sans doute en tête
des annulation de crédit qui avait été
prévu par la loi de finance
rectificative de mars
2012 ce précédent qui peut-être
intéressant
néanmoins ne peut-être comparé à I qui
anime les projets d'annulation de ce
collectif en effet en mars
2012 les annulations étaient de 1,2
milliards contre 1,6 milliards dans ce
PLFR en plus en 2012 les annulations
portaient uniquement sur des crédits
gelés alors que les annulations
d'aujourd'hui portent sur 1 milliard
d'euros de crédit situés hors réserve de
précaution enfin le gouvernement d'Alor
proposait en 2012 des annulations sans
savoir s'il lui reviendrait de tenir la
norme en fin d'année alors qu'il
diminuait par ailleurs nettement la
réserve de
précaution en réalité alors le risque
était pris dans le cadre d'un rabot que
ces annulations s'avèrent insoutenables
en fin d'année proposons pour notre part
que les annulations maintiennent la
réserve de précaution à un niveau élevé
de l'ordre de 6,8 milliards d'euros pour
garantir la bonne exécution en fin
d'année au final les dépenses de l'État
sous norme en valeur serait inférieure
de 3,1 milliard d'euros à l'exécution
2013 à périmètre constant cont tenu de
la baisse intervenue en loi de finance
initiale et des annulations qui vous
sont aujourd'hui
proposées ce PLFR anticipe par ailleurs
une charge de la dette inférieure de 1,8
milliard d'euros à la prévision de la
loi de finance initiale les taux
d'intérêt notamment sont plus bas
qu'attendus c'est le signe que la
politique économique et budgétaire du
gouvernement inspire confiance aux
créanciers de l'État je remarque qu'en
d'autres temps certains gouvernements
auraient pu être tenté de présenter
cette moindre dépense comme une économie
supplémentaire qui viendrait documenter
des men des mesures de redressement ce
n'est pas le choix qui a été fait cette
économie n'est en effet pas forcément
Périne il peut se produire une remontée
progressive des taux d'intérêt et de
l'inflation
par prudence nous nous contentons de
constater cette moindre dépense sans en
tirer la moindre conséquence pour
l'avenir ce projet de loi de finance
rectificative révise également les
recettes fiscales nettes de l'état de
5,3 milliards d'euros à la
baisse cette réévaluation tire les
conséquences de l'exécution de
2013 l'effet base c'est-à-dire les
moindres recettes constatées en fin
d'année 2013 par rapport à la prévision
vient minorer mécaniquement la prévision
pour 2014 à hauteur de 4 milliards
d'euros cont tenu de l'exécution 2013
nous proposons également de revoir à la
baisse de 2 milliards d'euros la
croissance spontanée des recettes fiscal
en particulier l'impôt sur le revenu et
l'impôt sur les
sociétés il faut garder une certaine
humilité quand on parle de prévision et
accepter le fait que l'exercice est
difficile
que la taxe sur la valeur ajoutée ou
l'impôt sur les sociétés soit moindre qu
compté mais il est également possible
que l'impôt sur le revenu soit plus
important que prévu ou que la charge de
la dette soit inférieure à nos
prévisions les informations nouvelles
qui apparaîtront dans les mois à venir
en particulier les
recouvrements et l'évolution de la
situation économique nous permettront
d'affiner nos
estimations jusqu'au dépôt du projet de
loi de finance pour
2015 puis du projet de loi de finance
rectificative de fin d'année au final
contenu de ces mouvements en recett et
en dépense le solde de l'État est revu à
la baisse de 1,4 milliards d'euros par
rapport à la prévision de
LFI monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs les mesures
adoptées dans toutes les lois de
finances depuis le début de la
législature ont eu pour objet de réduire
progressivement le déficit
mais ces mesures comme je le disais en
introduction ont également permis de
rétablir et d'améliorer la progressivité
de
l'impôt depuis le début de la
législature les mesures adoptées ont
certes mis chacun à
contribution mais l'effort demandé a été
proportionné au revenu de chacun ainsi
nous avons rétabli l'ISF qui avait été
vidé de sa substance par la funeste
réforme de
2011 n avons aussi rétabli les droits de
succession et de donation que la loi TPA
avait exagérément
minoré nous avons mis en place une
tranche d'impôt sur le revenu à 45 %.
nous avons abaissé le plafond du
cootient familial qui profite très
largement aux ménages les plus aisés
quand les ménages les plus modestes n'en
profite pas du tout dans le même temps
nous avons limité les effets pervers des
mesur prises précédemment en particulier
le gel du barê avec le renforcement de
la décôte et avec maintenant
l'allègement d'impôt sur le revenu
proposé par ce PLFR j'y reviendrai un
instant et l'allègement de cotisation
salariale prévu par le PLFR SS deux
mesures qui profiteront au ménages
moyens et
modeste enfin pour que personne personne
n'échappe à l'effort demandé à tous
nous avons renforcé les moyens de la
lutte contre la fraude fiscale avec le
succès que l'on peut mesurer aujourd'hui
avec la prise de conscience par nos
compatriotes qui avaient jusqu'ici omis
de déclarer des comptes à l'étranger que
les temps avait changé cette politique
nous permet en faisant payer l'impôt par
tous d'en rétablir plus justement la
charge avec la mesure d'allègement dès
2014 que propose ce
texte nous avons certes augmenté les
prélèvements obligatoires pour réduire
le déficit c'est vrai mais ces
augmentation ont permis de renforcer la
progressivité du système fiscal de
demander une plus grande contribution à
ceux qui ont davantage de revenus ou de
patrimoine dans le même temps les
augmentations sur les plus aisés
s'accompagnent d'allèchement pour les
plus modestes que le gouvernement vous
propose dans le cadre du Pacte il en va
ainsi d'une mesure d'allègement d'impôt
sur le revenu prévu par le présent
projet de loi de finance
rectificative d'un montant de 1,1
milliard
d'euros il en va aussi ainsi de
l'allègement de cotisation salariale que
vous examinerez dans le cadre du
pdfrss pour un montant de 2,5 milliards
d'euros ainsi pour un salarié rémunéré
au SMIC ce gain sera de l'ordre de 500
euros par an directement mesuré sur sa
fiche de
paye au total 5 milliards d'euros à
horizon 2017 de hausse du pouvoir
d'achat pour les ménages modestes et
moyens du début à la fin de la
législature notre politique fiscale
restera conforme à notre
objectif rétablir la progressivité du
système fiscal pour réduire les
inégalité enfin le gouvernement s'est
fixé comme priorité le retour à l'emploi
des les personnes qui en sont
aujourd'hui
dépourvues pour cela il mobilise
l'ensemble des moyens dont il dispose et
notamment l'outil
fiscal le gouvernement vous propose
ainsi d'alléger le coût du travail de 30
milliards d'euros sur l'ensemble de la
législature 20 milliards d'euros au
titre du crédit impôt compétitivité
emploi qui sont aujourd'hui complètement
appropriés par les entreprises dont
certaines le touche et dont toute
bénéficie à ce titre de réduction de
paiement de l'impôt sur les sociétés et
même parfois d'impôt sur le
revenu nous ajoutons 10 milliards
d'euros au titre des allègements de
cotisation patronnale proposé dans le
cadre du Pacte seuls seront inscrits
dans les deux textes que vous examinerez
les mesures qui entreront en vigueur en
2015 ce sont donc de nouveaux moyens au
service de l'emploi qui seront ainsi
mobilisé dans le même temps le
gouvernement vous proposera de supprimer
progressivement la contribution sociale
de solidarité sur les sociétés mais je
ne développe pas davantage car nous
aurons ce débat le débat sur ces sujets
dès la semaine prochaine monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs avec ce projet de loi de
finance rectificative le
gouvernement propose donc de poursuivre
à la fois l'assaainissement des finances
publiques le réétablissement de la progr
du système fiscal et l'effort menés en
faveur de l'emploi le débat autour des
propositions du gouvernement commence
donc aujourd'hui se poursuivra la
semaine prochaine avec l'examen du PLF
RSS pardon nous avons donc plusieurs
jours et peut-être plusieurs nuits de
débat passionnant dont je me réjouis en
vous
remerciant merci Monsieur le Ministre la
parole est à Monsieur François Mar
rapporteur général de la commission des
finances monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers
collègues le projet de loi de finances
rectificative pour 2014 qui nous est
soumis constitue avec le projet de loi
de finances rectificative de la sécurité
sociale que nous examinerons un
prochains jour la première traduction
législative du PACT de responsabilité de
solidarité on sait que celui-ci vise à
concilier le soutien à la croissance et
à l'emploi à l'aide de baisse ciblée de
prélèvement et la consolidation des
finances publiques qui prend la forme
d'un plan d'économie de 50 milliards
d'euros sur la période
2015-27 ces deux textes s'il ne
comprennent pas l'ensemble des mesures
législatives prévues par le pacte
permettent de tracer une perspective
pour l'évolution des dépenses publiques
mais aussi pour celle des prélèvements
obligatoires pour la suite de la
législature et au-delà cette visibilité
est essentielle on le sait pour le
retour de la confiance des acteurs
économiques après une période qui a
contraint les gouvernements successifs à
procéder à des ajustements fréquents
compte tenu de l'ampleur de la crise et
de ses effets sur les finances
publiques ainsi le pacte prévoit la site
de l'allègement du coût du travail
reposant dès 2015 sur la suppression des
cotisations patronales au niveau du SMIC
et la révision du barê des
alléchements compte tenu du cice le coût
du travail serait alléger vous l'avez
dit Monsieur le Ministre d'environ 30
milliards d'euros au total en
2017 il engage aussi une modernisation
de la fiscalité des entreprises qui fait
suite aux concertations intervenues dans
le cadre des Assises de la
fiscalité celle-ci privilégie la
diminution des impôts assis sur les
facteurs de production avec notamment
une suppression de la contribution
social des solidarités des sociétés la
C3S qui a été programmé sur plusieurs
années avec une première réduction de 1
milliard d'euros dès
2015 et il prévoit enfin la suppression
de la contribution exceptionnelle dite
surtaxe sur l'impôt sur les sociétés
puisque la suppression est actée pour
2016 par le présent projet de loi de
finance rectificative et il prévoit
aussi on le sait la diminution du taux
d'impôt sur les sociétés de 33 1/3 à 28
% d'ici à 2020 avec une première étape
en
2017 il prévoit enfin des mesures de
solidarité pour les ménages modestes
d'un montant total de plus de 6
milliards d'euros
comprenant une mesure provisoire
d'allègement sur l'impôt sur le revenu
qui figure dans le projet de loi de
finance rectificative et à laquelle
devrait succéder pour 2015 une mesure
pérenne portant sur le bas de
barem la prévision de recette fiscale
net pour 2014 est revue à la baisse de
5,3 milliard d'euros par rapport à la
loi de finance initiale et s'élève à 279
milliards d'euros et on sait que cela
résulte essentiellement du rendement
moins élevé qu'anticipé de l'IMP imp sur
le revenu et de l'impôt sur les sociétés
compteenu pour une large part de la
reprise en base des moins value des
recettes fiscales de 2013 pour un
montant de 4 milliards d'euros
s'agissant des dépenses de
l'état des annulations de crédit pour un
montant de 1,6 milliards d'euros sont
prévus sur le périmètre zéro valeur
c'est-à-dire horors charge de la dette
et des pensions afin de contribuer à
l'effort supplémentaire en dépenses de 4
milliards
d'euros les dépenses totales de l'État
en 2014 relevant du périmat zé volume
serait quant à elle inférieure de 3,4
milliards d'euros à la prévision
initiale en raison de la révision à la
baisse de la charge de la dette 1,8
milliards d'euros permise par la
faiblesse de l'inflation et des taux
d'intérêt on répellera à cet égard que
les taux sont historiquement bas avec un
taux à 10 ans autour de 1 6 % pour la
dette française et un spread avec
l'Allemagne de l'ordre de 40 points de
base et au fond mes chers collègu ceci
témoigne bien de la crédibilité de notre
politique mais aussi car l'ensemble des
taux d'intérêt se sont rapproché dans la
zone euro des progrès que cette zone
euro a réalisé tant du point de vue des
efforts accomplis que des avancé en
terme de gouvernance au cours des
derniers mois quant aux annulations de
crédit elle porte essentiellement à
hauteur de 965 millions d'euros sur des
crédits qui n'avaient pas été mis en
réserve en début d'année et 635 millions
d'euros sont annulés au sein de la
réserve de précaution elles n'ont pas
porté sur les dépenses obligatoires et
pratiquement pas sur les dépenses de
personnel seul les dépenses pleinement
maîtrisables par les gestionnaire étant
concerné donc dans ces conditions notera
que d'importantes marges de manœuvre
sont malgré tout conservé afin d'assurer
le respect de la norme de dépenses en
exécution puisque les crédits mis en
réserve seraient encore de
6,8 milliards d'euros après les
annulation de ce projet de loi de
finance rectificative cela devrait
permettre de faire face aux différents
alléales de l'exécution budgétaire comme
par exemple les dépenses qui pourraient
résulter des contentieux agricoles avec
la Commission européenne
au total le projet de loi de finance
rectificative prévoit un déficit
budgétaire de 83,9 milliards d'euros y
compris les investissements d'avenir
certes cela correspond à un déficit
accru de 1,4 milliards d'euros par
rapport à la loi de finance initiale
mais à une amélioration d'environ 3
milliards d'euros par rapport à
l'exercice 2013 sur lequel nous
reviendrons dans quelques
jours le présent projet de loi de
finance rectificative poursuit avec le
rfss l'effort de consolidation des
comptes publiques engagés par le
gouvernement en 2012 cet effort a été
considérable il n'a toutefois pas
produit les effets escomptés compte tenu
de la conjoncture économique déprimé à
l'échelle mondiale et tout
particulièrement au sein de la zone euro
c'est la raison pour laquelle a été
déclenché le mécanisme de correction
budgétaire le Haut Conseil des finances
publiques ayant identifié dans son avis
du 23 mai
2014 ce qu'on appelle un écart important
entre le sol de structurel constaté en
2013 et les orientations arrêtées par la
loi de programmation des finances
publiques pour les années 2012 à
2017 l'effort projetés en 2014 dans ces
conditions plus important que ne le
prévoit la loi de
programmation va permettre d'engager la
correction de cet
écart cette ution est mise en évidence
par l'article liminaire qui retrace les
prévisions de solde effectif et
structurel alors j'ai noté et la
commission des finances en a débattu que
l'Assemblée nationale a modifié cet
article liminaire nous aurons l'occasion
d'y revenir tout à l'heure en dégradant
la prévision de sold conjoncturel et en
améliorant celle du solde structurel
cela revient à modifier notre croissance
potentiel et à nous rapprocher du retour
vers l'équilibre structurel je souhaite
indiquer d'emblé qu'une telle
réévaluation en cours de route n'est pas
souhaitable au contraire une permanence
dans les méthodes et les hypothèses
fondamentales utilisé pour le calcul du
solde structurel me paraîtent
indispensable c'est d'ailleurs à cette
fin que nous avons défini une
trajectoire de PIB potentiel dans la loi
de programmation des finances publiques
et que le Haut Conseil des finances
publiques à la suite d'une modification
apportée par le Sénat à l'initiative de
notre collègue Jean-Pierre cafet est
tenue de retenir je cite la trajectoire
du produit intérieur brut potentiel
figurant dans le rapport annexé à la loi
de
programmation et je dirais que au
surplus le non respect de ce cadre
budgétaire comme nous le suggère
l'Assemblée nationale
pourrait porter atteinte à la
crédibilité de la France auprès de nos
partenaires et fragiliser les règles de
gouvernance économique et financière en
effet s'écarter des méthodes définies
dans not texte donnerait le sentiment
que les autorités français s'arroge le
droit d'améliorer comme bon leur semble
leur trajectoire de solde
structurel ces éléments expliquent que
la commission des finances est adopté je
crois pouvoir dire de manière unanime un
amendement visant à revenir au texte
initial du
gouvernement en dépit des nombreux
articles insérés lors de l'examen du
texte par l'Assemblée nationale je
rappelle que leur nombre des articles a
été multiplié par 5 le sol budgétaire
pour 2014 n'a pas été modifié je
souhaite évoquer deux articles adoptés
par l'Assemblée nationale qui me SEM
particulièrement important pour la vie
de nos territoires en premier lieu le
remplacement de
l'écotaxe par un péage de transit poids
lourd cette solution permet me
semble-t-il de préserver la logique
pollueur payeur tout en évitant de
mettre en place un dispositif qui
n'était ni compris ni accepté je me
félicite que sur ce sujet sensible une
solution équilibrée a été trouvée en
second lieu je voulais évoquer la taxe
locale sur la consommation finale
d'électricité j'avais dès l'examen du
projet de loi de finance pour 2014
contester la réforme proposée par le
gouvernement le Sénat m'avait suivi et à
ce printemps adopté à l'unanimité une
proposition de loi de notre collègue
Jacques mzard et du groupe RDSE allant
dans le même sens le Sénat ne peut donc
que se satisfaire du maintien de la
situation actuelle que propose le projet
de loi de finance rectificative qui nous
est
soumis la poursuite du redressement de
nos finances publiques est un impératif
bien il passe par des efforts importants
des année en 2015 ce sont 21 milliards
d'euros d'économie qui devront être
réalisé les dépenses publiques devraient
êre ainsi progresser moins vite que
l'inflation ce qui constitue un effort
inédit il repose sur des réformes
permettant de réduire structurellement
la dépense publique et garantir un
redressement
pérenne la mise en œuvre des réforme le
Premier ministre l'a rappelé il y a
quelques jours nécessite du courage
de la cohésion et de la
constance les économies programmées
nécessiteront en effet de réformer en
profondeur nos manières de piloter et de
mettre en œuvre les politiques publiques
n'ayons pas la faiblesse de croire que
nous y arriverons seulement en réduisant
le train de vie de l'État ou en
supprimant ici ou là des dépenses des
structures publ cela est sans doute
nécessaire mais l'essentiel des
économies à consentir doit doivent
résulter d'une révision plus profonde de
la mise en œuvre des politiques qui doit
contribuer également à une plus grande
équité une modernisation de nos services
publics et une simplification de nos
règles et
procédures la méthode sera déterminante
il faudra de la transparence sur les
objectifs de la concertation quant au
choix des moyens pour les atteindre et
de la fermeté dans la mise en œuvre des
décisions il me semble enfin que notre
effort d'ajustement doit prendre en
compte deux dimensions
essentielles
l'investissement soit la préparation de
l'avenir et la lutte contre les
inégalités qui conditionnent notre
cohésion sociale nous le savons les
politiques d'ajustement ont des
conséquences négatives sur ces deux
dimensions y compris dans l'Europe tout
entiè cette préoccupation doit donc être
prise en compte à plusieurs niveaux de
l'action publique elle
suppose que des politiques
redistributives efficaces soi mises en
œuvre c'est le sens des mesures fiscales
et sociales prises par le gouvernement
dont j'ai parlé tout à l'heure
elle exige aussi que les dépenses
d'investissement on a pu parler aussi de
dépenses d'avenir car il est vrai que la
notion comptable d'investissement n'est
pas nécessairement
adapté ne soit pas sacrifié sur l'Hôtel
De La cont
budgétaire c'est le sens notamment du
deuxème programme d'investissement
d'avenir engagé par le gouvernement dont
il faut sans doute simplifier les
procédures pour en accélérer la mise en
œuvre monsieur le ministre il est
indispensable de la même manière que la
réduction programmée des concours
financiers de l'État aux collectivités
territoriales prennent en compte ces
deux dimensions en inventant des
mécanismes permettant certes de
favoriser des économies structurelles
mais aussi de préserver
l'investissement tout en poursuivant la
montée en charge des mécanisme de
péréquation enfin il convient de
faciliter et d'encourager
l'investissement des entreprises qui est
une source essentielle de croissance et
sera demain avec la diminution du coût
du travail le principal outil de la
compétitivité de notre économie c'est ce
qui guide l'action du gouvernement à
travers le cice et les mesures du PACT
de responsabilité et de Solidar
tel est également la vocation de la
banque publique d'investissement et des
autres dispositifs publics destiné à
financer les entreprises innovantes la
visibilité donnée par le gouvernement
sur l'évolution des prélèvements
obligatoire est également de nature à
favoriser la confiance et par conséquent
une reprise plus vigoureuse de
l'investissement mes chers collègues
chacun le comprend la croissance est la
clé à la fois du redressement de
finances publiqu et la condition de la
préservation de notre système productif
c'est elle qui permettra de nous
désendetter d'investir de réduire le
chômage et de dégager des marges de
manœuvre pour mettre en œuvre nos
priorités en cela il est nécessaire de
s'interroger sur nos règles et modes de
fonctionnement au sein de la zone euro
c'est pourquoi je salue la convergence
de vue qui se dessine entre le
gouvernement français et le président du
Conseil italien
auenzi le débat sur le rythme des
ajustements dans l'Union européenne et
ses effets sur l'emploi l'investissement
et la croissance est pleinement légitime
de même que celui concernant notre
politique monétaire commune ce sont
d'ailleurs les instances internationales
Fond Monétaire International et OCDE qui
le pose autant que les pays membres de
la zone euro il conduit à évoquer de
nombreuses questions essenti pour
l'avenir de la zone euro au-delà des
enjeux de court terme je veux parler de
l'assouplissement des conditions
d'application du PACT de stabilité et de
croissance la création d'une capacité
budgétaire propre au sein de la zone
euro la mise en place d'un salaire
minimum différencié dans l'ensemble de
la
zone ou encore la mutualisation d'une
partie des dettes par exemple pour
financer des investissements
structurants qu'il s'agisse
d'infrastructure de transport de
transition énergétique ou d'économie
numérique les sujets pour lesquels des
investissements conséquents seraient
nécessaires pour favoriser la croissance
et le bien-être en Europe ne manque
pas ce débat chers collègues invite à
aussi à mieux coordonner les politique
budgétaire nationale à cet égard
l'ajustement conduit par l'Allemagne qui
dispose d'un excédent commercial jugé je
cite excessif par la Commission
européenne mais continue pour autant de
pratiquer une modération salariale et
équilibre son budget au détriment pour
partie de ces dépenses d'investissement
public pose question cet ajustement
conduit en effet à la fois à déprimer la
demande et à réduire la capacité de la
plupart des autres pays de la zone euro
à rattraper leur déficit de
compétitivité il accroit également la
commission des finances en a longuement
parlé ces dernières semaines il accroit
les risques de déflation qui s'il devait
se matérialiser nuirait considérablement
à notre capacité de redresser nos
comptes publics et à retrouver
collectivement une croissance
forte ces questions sont essentielles et
mérit d'être débattu publiquement
elles ne peuvent pour autant
justifier elle ne peut pour autant
justifier que nous modifions nos règles
de calcul ou que nous ne tenions pas nos
engagements
elles ne peuvent pas davantage remettre
en cause la nécessité de réduire la
charge que nous laissons aux générations
futures et de mener à bien les réformes
qui nous permettront de retrouver des
marges de manœuvre
budgétaire l'investissement public me
vous l'aurez donc tous bien compris être
un paramètre à regarder avec beaucoup
d'attention tant au niveau européen que
national ainsi qu'à l'échelle locale il
nous faudra très vite revenir sur cette
question de l'investissement public et
pour conclure je rappellerai ici ayant
dit tout cela que la commission des
finances a décider de proposer au Sénat
d'adopter ce projet de loi de finance
rectificative je vous
remercie merci monsieur le rapporteur
général la parole est à Monsieur
Philippe Marini président de la
commission des
finances monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues je commencerai par un
paradoxe vous nous présentez monsieur le
ministre les textes successifs du
gouvernement et par exemple ce projet de
loi de finances
rectificative comme jalon sur le chemin
du retour à l'équilibre des comptes
publics or pour ma part quand je regarde
les choses de manière un peu approfondie
j'ai tendance à considérer que ce chemin
est de moins en moins ambitieux et de
plus en plus sinueux ou flou et je
voudrais tâcher de vous le montrer
d'abord il me semble que nous ne cessons
de réviser en baisse nos ambitions en
matière de finances publiques premier
exemple dans ce collectif budgétaire
qu'est-ce qui éclate aux yeux sur la
première page les recettes diminuent de
4,8 milliards d'euros les dépenses de
3,4 milliards d'euros le solde se
dégrade de 1,3 1,4 milliards
d'euros 2e élément la dégradation du
déficit de l'État en 2014 fait suite à
la révision dans le programme de
stabilité dont nous avons débattu fin
avril de l'objectif de solde des
administrations publiques pour 2014 il
était de -3,6 % il est à présent de -
3,8 % ambition
réduite 3è
exemple vous annoncez 4 milliards
d'euros d'économie
supplémentaire en réalité ces économies
ne viennent pas majorer l'effort en
dépense de 2014 mais
compenser d'autres dépenses qui
augmentent de façon plus dynamique que
prévu au moment de la loi de finance
initiale si l'on raisonne en terme
structurel au niveau de l'effort
structurel l'objectif fixé en loi de
finance initiale était de
09 point de PIB il n'est plus à présent
que de
0,8 4 milliards d'euros d'économie
supplémentaire pour un effort structurel
moins important c'est encore une
ambition
réduite nous verrons un peu plus tard
dans le débat d'orientation des finances
publiques que par ailleurs ces économies
ne permettent pas de corriger
intégralement l'écart à la trajectoire
constaté par le Haut Conseil des
finances publiques et que vous avez
évoqué monsieur le ministre ainsi que
notre excellent rapporteur général 4e
exemple au-delà de 2014 le programme de
stabilité du mois d'avril acte un
relâchement de l'effort budgétaire sur
la période de programmation qui court
jusqu'à
2017 puisque l'objectif de retour à
l'équilibre effectif des comptes publics
en 2017 qui était
encore l'engagement de campagne de
l'actuel président de la République
c'est'est éloigné c'est estompé dans le
temps la prévision pour 2017 est à
présent celle d'un solde négatif de 1
% quant à la cible de l'équilibre
structurel qui constitue depuis le
traité européen de 2011 et notre loi
organique de décembre 2012 l'objectif de
moyen terme de nos finances publiques
faute de pouvoir être atteint dans les
temps cet objectif a été décalé à 2017
c'est toujours une ambition dégradée de
maîtrise de nos finances publiques et
dernier exemple celui-ci est relatif à
la dette et sans doute encore plus
décisif pour 2014 la loi de
programmation que nous a présenté le
gouvernement il y a moins de 2 ans
Monsieur le Ministre fixait un objectif
de
90,5 % du produit intérieur brut oui
c'était la même
majorité ce n'était pas le même
gouvernement puisque c'était celui de
Monsieur hérro mais vous étiez
rapporteur général et cet objectif de
90,5 % du PIB a été porté plus tard 6
mois plus tard à
94,3 % dans le programme de stabilité
d'avril
2013 puis à
95,1 % par la loi de financeces pour
2014 puis à
95,6 % par le programme de stabilité du
mois d'avril 2014 alors on nous dit
certains nous disent que cette austérité
est absolument insupportable et
dramatique mais ce que je vois pour ma
part c'est que les objectifs ne cesse de
se dégrader et le plus préoccupant
d'entre eux d'abord qui est celui de
l'endettement de l'État objectif de 90 %
il y a 2 ans objectif de près de 96 %
aujourd'hui quant à ce chemin peu
ambitieux il me semble également
caractérisé par un
flou on aimerait disposer monsieur le
ministre pour chacune des années
jusqu'en 2017 non seulement des
objectifs du solde effectif et
structurel mais aussi des mesures en
dépens et en recette année par année qui
serait susceptible d'être mise en œuvre
cela paraît être une évidence ainsi
énoncé mais pourtant nous n'avons pas
cette présentation dans le collec
budgétaire ni davantage dans le rapport
sur les orientations des finances
publiques sur lequel nous allons
débattre d'ici quelques jours on nous
répète c'est la communication constante
de ce gouvernement que le pacte de
responsabilité consiste en 50 milliards
d'euros d'économie de dépenses et en 25
milliards d'euros d'allégement de
prélèvements obligatoires soit un effort
de 25 milliards d'euros de réduction du
déficit d'ici
2017 monsieur le ministre ces 25
milliards d'euros permettront-ils
d'atteindre les objectifs fixés à
l'horizon 2017 et que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure nul ne le sait rien ne le
démontre dans les documents qui nous
sont
diffusés le gouvernement peut-être le
sait-il mais en tout cas il ne le dit
pas
clairement puisque évoque ainsi quelques
zones d'ombre je laisserai aux membres
de mon groupe qui ont l'intention de le
faire à juste titre le soin de disséquer
les mesures proposées dans ce collectif
budgétaire et j'achèverai par quelques
réflexion sur la gouvernance de nos
finances publiques pour vous
exprimer mes doutes mes doutes profond
sur la gouvernance de nos finances
publiques en premier lieu nous sommes en
quelque sorte victime du fractionnement
des débats financier nous allons
examiner successivement un collectif
budgétaire et une loi rectificative de
financement de la sécurité sociale
chacun sait qu'entre l'un et l'autre
texte il existe une tuyoterie d'une
complexité incroyable et que faire re
ces deux systèmes parallèles ne peut que
se traduire par un vrai problème de
lisibilité
politique nous avons un peu progressé
mais très insuffisamment sur le chemin
d'une approche consolidée des finances
publiques mais monsieur le ministre pour
informer correctement le Parlement et
l'opinion publique la seule bonne
solution c'est de suiv suivre l'avis
formulé dès 2010 par la commission quand
dessus c'est de
fusionner les parties recettes de la loi
de financeces et de la loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale au
demeurant le Haut Conseil des finances
publiques a joué son rôle il ne s'y'est
pas trompé et ses avis sont globaux et
portent à la fois sur l'un et l'autre
texte loi de finance et loi de
financement
second doute que j' Metet sur notre
gouvernance des finances publiques c'est
le recours à une règles exprimées en
terme de soldes structurel c'est le
recours à des notions abstraites et
intellectuel tel que le Produit
Intérieur Brut potentiel une règle
fondée sur un sur un raisonnement
structurel peut sans doute mes chers
collègues produire le meilleur comme le
pire le meilleur ce serait qu'en isolant
ce qui relève de la conjoncture et ce
qui relève des décisions politiques on
incite les gouvernements et leur
majorités à prendre leur responsabilité
et à annoncer clairement les mesures
qu'ils entendent adopter pour rétablir
structurellement les finances
publiques malheureusement
euh ce n'est pas euh vraiment ce que
nous observons du moins en France et
pour moi le
gouvernement de façon volontaire
ou par l'enchaînement des choses me
semble s'attacher à désincarner en
quelque sorte la politique
budgétaire un exemple dans la loi de
finances pour 2014 le gouvernement a
anticipé le fait que la trajectoire de
solde structurel ne serait pas respecté
en 2003 13 et qu'il faudrait prendre des
mesures compensatoires en
2014 qu'est-ce que l'on aurait pu en
attendre en bon sens que le gouvernement
dise quelles économies supplémentaires
il mettrait en œuvre pour compenser le
dérapage que s'est-il passé l'effort
structurel prévu pour 2014 est passé de
0,5 à 0,9 % sans autrees forme de précis
on ne nous dit plus ce que l'on va faire
on nous demande de faire confiance aux
objectifs fixés en quelque sorte d'avoir
la foi et on crée une sorte de rideau de
fumée par rapport à la réalité de la
gestion budgétaire or qu'est-ce qui nous
préoccupe c'est de distinguer les vraies
et les fausses économies de tout temps
et cela fait partie de leur rôle les
gouvernements ont cherché à embellir la
mariée à débudgétiser dans l'instant
pour dépenser plus tout en donnant
l'impression d'être économe quel
gouvernement n'a pas fait cela c'est
assurément ce que vous faites en
utilisant opportunément le programme des
investissements d'avenir pour accroître
par exemple certains crédits de la
dépense de la défense j'allais dire
c'est de bonne guerre mais s'agissant de
la programmation des finances publiques
et de la trajectoire de soldes
structurel nous sommes dans une
situation très différente puisque les
outils à notre disposition abstraits et
conventionnels permettent au
gouvernement de présenter des économies
fictives en particulier en faisant un
usage excessif de la notion de
tendantiel le gouvernement euh au lieu
de donner la liste des économies
réellement pratiquées raisonne en
tendance et illustre ses décisions non
pas par de réelles économies mais par
une différence par rapport à la tendance
acquise par la dépense publique eu j'ai
l'impression par exemple que le
Gouvernement détermine de nombreuses
économie en projetant la tendance
d'évolution des dépenses non pas sur la
base de l'exécution 2013 mais sur la
base de la prévision retenue à l'automne
2013 et en partant ainsi d'un point de
départ plus haut on obtient
effectivement un montant d'économie plus
important par rapport à la tendance
enfin nous le savons bien les chiffres
des finances publiques peuvent toujours
et c'est une tentation qui peut nous
nous atteindre les uns et les autres
être manipulés à des fins politiques et
c'est la tentation à laquelle nos
collègues de l'Assemblée nationale ont
enfin n'ont pas résisté avec leur
amendement à l'article liminire
qu'évoquait le rapporteur général et qui
réduit le déficit structurel de 2014
comme si le changement de thermomètre
pouvait avoir un effet sur la
température et c'est un risque que je
soulligne risque résultant d'une
gouvernance des finances publiques qui
repose à l'excès sur des notions
abstraites ce qui peut conduire à des
initiatives
d'opportunités de nature à miner encore
plus la crédibilité de notre pays en
conclusion mes chers collègues le
consentement à l'impôt le vote du budget
c'est bien sûr l'essence
même de notre légitimité et d'où
l'insatisfaction que l'on peut avoir
dans un débat comme
celui-ci lorsque l'on a le sentiment que
les cartes sont biaisées et que la
méthode n'est pas la plus propice pour
permettre à ce débat démocratique
d'avoir lieu dans les meilleures
conditions
possibles
maintenant mes chers collègues
eu et c'est le dernier point nos règles
permettront-elles d'atteindre l'objectif
pour lequel elles ont été conçues
c'est-à-dire revenir à l'équilibre des
finances publique ne faudrait-il pas que
nous
sachions voir de manière plus exigeante
la réalité de nos
budgets ce
qui je je le suppose nous conduirait à à
redéfinir certaines de nos règles de
procédure pour l'examen des lois de
finances afin de rendre les débats
budgétaires qu'il s'agisse de l'État et
de ou de la sécurité sociale plus
concret et de nature à mieux associer
nos concitoyens aux choix qui devront
être fait pour que notre pays réellement
s'engage sur la voie du redressement
mais chers collègues la commission des
finances a suivi l'avis de son
rapporteur général pour ce qui est de
l'ensemble du texte mais tout à l'heure
en examinant les amendements nous avons
rejeté l'article 1er et l'article 2 de
ce texte ce qui ne préjuge pas des
autres votes qui auront lieu sur les
différents amendements que nous allons
examiner en
particulier à partir de la suspension de
ce soir merci mes chers collègues de de
m'avoir
écouté merci monsieur le Président dans
la suite de la discussion générale la
parole est à Monsieur André gatolin pour
le groupe
écologie 50 7h3 on va
finir monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
voilà donc nous renouons avec cette
tradition d'un collectif budgétaire au
seul 6 d'été les gouvernement du
précédent qu Kena on avait usé tanté si
bien que nous avions été presque surpris
l'an passé de ne pas avoir été gratifié
de cet exercice un projet de loi de
finance rectificatif a généralement pour
objet de corriger les prévisions de la
loi de finance initiale ou encore et
sans que cela soit exclusif d'infléchir
sensiblement la politique budgétaire en
cours cours d'exercice alors si on en
croit l'exposé des motifs de ce PLFR
c'est plutôt le second objectif qui est
recherché ici avec cette particularité
que l'inflexion proposée doit s'entendre
plutôt au sens de la vitesse et non pas
de la direction le président de la
République et le Premier ministre l'ont
expliqué sans relâche le pacte de
responsabilité tardivement orné mais
orné quand même de solidarité à vocation
à prolonger amplifier des multiplier le
cice le crédit d'impôt pour la
compétitivité et l'emploi les
écologistes ayant fortement critiqué
cette mesure tant sur la forme que sur
le fond vous comprendrez monsieur le
ministre qu'il ne voit pas d'un œil
particulièrement bienveillant la non
remise à plat de ce dispositif les
écologistes ne considèrent pas
nécessaire que toutes les entreprises
soient systématiquement aidées qu'elles
soi exposé ou bien protégé qu'elles soit
en difficulté ou bien furissante
qu'elles soi économe en ressources ou
bien très pelluante à forciori lorsque
ces aides sont financées par des couples
dans certains budgets publics dans les
prestations sociales et dans les
investissements des collectivités
territoriales les écologistes ne se
reconnaissent pas non plus dans le
postulat énoncé par le Président de la
République selon lequel l'OF crée la
demande les chefs d'entreprises qui se
refusent à toute contrepartie à ces 41
milliards qui leur sont promis explique
eux- même et a raison que sans commande
ils ne pourront pas créer d'emploi à ce
propos monsieur le ministre puisque
l'objectif premier de cette politique
était et reste l'emploi et que nous n'en
voyons en la matière guerre
d'amélioration sensible pourriez-vous
nous fournir les éléments chiffrés
permettant d'apprécier les conséquences
concrètes de la mise en œuvre du cice
que par ce Pact de responsabilité vous
entendez prolonger car le moins que l'on
puisse dire c'est que nous ne croulons
pas sous les données le CCE été
introduit lors du PLFR de 2013 par voie
d'amendement dispensant ainsi le gouvern
de toute étude d'impact préalable plus
récemment nous avons appris par
l'entremise de la rapporteur générale
des finances de l'Assemblée nationale
Madame Valérie rabau que le gouvernement
gardait pardevers lui une simulation du
Trésor assez édifiante selon ses calculs
les mesure de soutien aux entreprises et
dans une moindre mesure au ménages
devrait générer 190000 emplois et 06
points de croissance cumulée à l'horizon
2017 tandis que les 50 milliards
d'économies annoncé dans le programme de
stabilité devrait engendrer à la même
échéance la suppression de 250000
emplois et une baisse de croissance de
1,4 points cumulés environ dans ces
conditions ne faudrait-il pas réorienter
dès ce PLFR la politique budgétaire dans
le sens d'une plus grande
conditionnalité et efficacité des aides
accordées aux entreprises en particulier
en incitant davantage les entreprises à
investir plutôt qu'à distribuer des
dividendes à leurs actionnaires et en
resserrant le dispositif sur les PME à
fort potentiel
d'exportation outre le PACT de
responsabilité je souhaitais également
évoquer deux autres mesures du PLFR qui
concentrent la l'attention du groupe
écologiste d'abord la réduction de
l'impôt sur le revenu portant sur un peu
plus d'un milliard à l'adresse des
ménages les plus modeste cette mesure
qui d'après le gouvernement entraînerait
une baisse d'impôt de 350 € 700 € pour
un couple était attendu elle permettra
de compenser le gel du barê décidé dans
le précédent quinquena ajoutter
allègements de cotisation sociale du
PLFR SS elle constitue une inflexion
positive son financement toutefois n'est
assuré que pour cette année puisqu'il
repose largement sur des recettes
exceptionnelles les fameuses Rex en
l'occurrence des pénalité perçu par
l'État dans le cadre de sa lutte accrue
contre la fraude fiscale il sera donc
nécessaire pour préserver cette mesure
compensatoire de trouver lors de la
prochaine loi de finance une recette
pérenne la seconde mesure que je vous
voulais évoquer est le remplacement de
l'écotaxe sur les transports routiers de
marchandise par ce qui a été dénommé le
péage de transit poids lourd et qui
diffèrre de la première mouture
essentiellement par le fait que le
réseau auquel s'appliquera ce dispositif
a été divisé par 4 je ne m'apesantiai
pas sur la NAS dans laquelle était
effectivement tombée cette mesure je me
permettrai simplement de regretter que
vous n'ayez pas davantage prise en
compte les conclusions de la mission
d'information parlementaire sur le sujet
comme la proposition d'une franchise
applicable au premier kilomètre mais
au-delà du débat technique et politique
sur le dispositif cette réforme de
l'écotaxe laisse un manque à gagner
fiscal d'environ 650 millions d'euros
annuels qui aurait dû servir au
financement d'infrastructure de
transport pourriez-vous nous dire
monsieur le ministre par quelle recette
ces 650 millions seront
remplacés alors s'il permet d'introduire
d'importantes mesures politiques en
cours d'exercice le PLFR permet
également de revoir certain nombre
d'hypothèses de conjoncture en fonction
des premières réalisations de ces
premières réalisations d'abord
j'aimerais évoquer la bonne surprise
celle de la charge de la dette qui est
revue à la baisse de 1,8 milliard
d'euros cette situation favorable ne
doit toutfois pas nous inciter au
triomphalisme c'est en effet la
politique de la Banque centrale
européenne qui assure une abondante
liquidité aux banque tout en accueillant
les dépôts qui a des taux négatifs qui
conduent aujourd'hui les investisseurs à
se porter massivement sur les emprunts
d'État européens faisant donc baisser
les taux pour la France ce sont ainsi
0,8 milliards d'euros économisé de la du
fait de la baisse de ces taux le
milliard restant est dû à la baisse de
la charge des titres indexé sur
l'inflation c'est donc la tendance
déflationniste pesant sur l'économie
européenne dont on ne peut pas dire
qu'elle constitue un horizon
particulièrement réjouissant qui permet
aujourd'hui d'économiser ce milliard
cela étant dit pour une fois que nous
faisons face à une bonne nouvelle nous
n'allons pas bouder notre plaisir en ce
qui concerne la croissance l'hypothèse
de 1 % pour 2014 qui avait présidé à
l'élaboration de la loi de finance
initiale correspondait alors au
consensus des économistes après une
croissance nulle au premier trimestre de
cette année cette hypothèse devient
nécessairement moins probable dans son
avis le Haut conseil aux finances
publiques l'a d'ailleurs juger désormais
entre guillemets élevé et comme on
pouvait s'y attendre le FMI vient de
déprécier son appréciation à 0,7 % pour
2014 dès lors on peut se demander
monsieur le ministre ce qui a conduit le
gouvernement à maintenir coûte que coûte
cette hypothèse haute déjà lors du PLFR
pour 2013 environ 11 milliards d'euros
manquaient à l'inventaire des recettes
fiscales cette fois la dégradation du
sol budgétaire en l'occurrence une
différence entre deux diminutions celle
des recettes et celle des dépenses se
monte à 1,4 milliards d'euros texte
après texte année après année nous avons
le sentiment que le gouvernement ne
parvient pas à admettre ou tout au moins
correctement évaluer les effets
récessifs de sa politique de réduction
drastique du déficit public cela vous a
conduit dans ce PLFR à annoncer 4
milliards d'économies supplémentaires de
dépenses publiques dont 1,6 milliards
s'applique directement au budget de
l'État faut faut faut-il donc bien
comprendre monsieur le ministre que
c'est 4 milliards viennent s'ajouter aux
50 milliards d'économie déjà annoncé ou
non à cet ha nous considérons que les
objectifs fixés par le gouvernement ne
sont pas raisonnables comment
parviendrez-vous à réaliser l'année
prochaine l'effort prévu de 21 milliards
d'économies de dépenses publiques cette
divergence permanente entre les annonces
et l'exécution qui consiste à compter
sur des milliards que l'on n'a pas
conduit à des situations de plus en plus
dangereuses qui à certains égards
peuvent parfois s'apparenter une sorte
de cavalerie le budget de la défense en
constitue le triste exemple dans son
rapport sur l'exécution du budget 2013
la Cour des comptes écrit je cite les
crédits de la mission défense pour 2014
ont été amputés de 0,4 milliards d'euros
pour financer les dépenses de 2013 des
crédits de programme d'investissement
d'avenir de la LFI 2014 ont en effet été
utilisé en janvier 2014 pour payer une
fraction de la subvention du CEA au
titre de 2013 si cette opération a
permis de diminuer les restes à payer de
la mission elle a réduit d'autant les
crédits disponibles pour l'exercice 2014
je continue ser la citation de ce
rapport ainsi le Pia ne va pas financer
1,5 milliards d'euros de dépenses de
2014 mais seulement environ 1,1 milliard
ce qui nuit à la sincérité de la loi de
finance pour 2014 et pourrait aboutir à
des difficultés budgétaires pour la
direction des applications militaires du
CEA en 2014 un écologiste qui vous parle
de la défense vous vous demandez
pourquoi vous allez comprendre la
solution d'urgence que vous avez trouvé
monsieur le ministre consiste à
transférer et que vous appliquez dans ce
PLFR consiste à transférer à la
recherche nucléaire du CEA 250 millions
de crédits non consommés du PIA or pour
220 millions d'entre eux ces millions
sont prix sur deux programmes intitulés
tenez-vous bien innovation pour la
transition écologique et énergétique et
ville et territoire durable non
seulement les investissements dit
d'avenir ne servent donc qu'à
débudgetiser des dépenses auxquelles on
ne parvient plus à faire face dévoyant
ainsi complètement le sens du PIA non
seulement les crédits extra budgétaire
promis en l'occurrence à la défense
n'arrive pas transformant des recettes
exceptionnelles en général et du PIA en
particulier en monnaette plus que
virtuelle mais cet épisode permet de
réaliser qu'il existe dans le P a des
centaines de millions dédiés à
l'écologie et qui ne sont pas utilisés
sans doute n'y a-t-il aucun besoin
d'investissement d'avenir en France
aujourd'hui en en matière de transition
écologique et énergétique comme en
matière de ville durable ce transfert
douteux illustre en tout cas le bien
faible attachement que ce gouvernement
porte à la transition écologique
sacrifié au nucléaire militaire nous
défendrons un amendement visant à
rétablir l'ambition écologique de la
majorité et nous serons extrêmement
vigilants sur les réponses que vous nous
apporterez à ce propos en conclusion
monsieur le ministre le groupe
écologiste n'est pas convaincu à ce
stade de la discussion budgétaire par ce
les faire et il attend un rééquilibrage
au profit des ménages de la transition
écologique et de l'emploi aux antipodes
de l'amplification d'une politique de
l'offre indifférenciée de la division
par quadre du réseau de l'écotaxe du
transfert de crédit d'avenir dédié à
l'écologie vers le nucléaire militaire
pour toutes ces raisons les sénatrices
et les sénateurs écologistes attendront
la fin de nos débats et les réponses que
vous aurez bien voulu apporter à nos
interrogations pour arrêter leur
position de vote sur ce PLFR je vous
remercie merci Monsieur gatolin la
parole est à Monsieur Emer de montescu
pour le groupe udi
UC monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je l'ai
souvent répété depuis le début du quin
l'héritage reçu en mai 2012 était
lourd il était dû en grande partie à la
crise de 2008 que vous reconnaissez
enfin et que vous invoquez aujourd'hui
avec 6 années de
retard en mai 2014 cet héritage a
dramatiquement
fructifié on compte 395000 chômeurs de
plus un
record la dette avoisine les 2000
milliards d'euros soit 30000 € par
habitant un
record 20 % de permis de construire en
moins un record et cela avec des
conséquences importantes sur l'emploi
notre déficit commercial s'aggrave selon
la Commission européenne la trajectoire
budgétaire dérape le déficit public
s'établit à 3,8 % au lieu des 3,6 prévu
et le mécanisme de correction budgétaire
est désormais
déclenché c'est dans la cohérence et la
continuité que se joue la solidité et la
réussite de notre politique économique
vous avez raison monsieur le ministre
pourtant la politique économique et
fiscale depuis 2 ans n'a pas mis en
œuvre cette préconisation
elle en a même pris le contrepied où est
la cohérence où est la
continuité le gouvernement héros avait
augmenté les impôts et les charges sur
les entreprises de 28 milliards sur les
ménages de 15 à 17 milliards selon les
estimations il s'est évertué de années
durant à éteindre le feu de la crise en
l'alimentant par une taxation
compulsive la Cour des comptes a
souligné les limites d'une stratégie
concentrée trop exclusivement sur
l'augmentation des recettes cette
stratégie a provoqué comme je vous
l'avais prédit un affaiblissement des
recettes des impôts sur le revenu sur
les sociétés en 2013 et de la TVA en
2012 la multiplication des mesures
nouvelles a créé une incertitude quant à
la stabilité de la fiscalité cette
politique a surtout généré 8 milliards
de recettes en moins en 2013 et 4,8
milliards en moins prévu en 2014 et
peut-être plus est-il nécessaire de
rappeler encore une fois que trop
d'impôt tu l'impôt monsieur le ministre
Sapin a lui-même souligné hier que la
coupe fiscale était pleine et qu'elle
stérilisait l'économie avec un taux de
prélèvement obligatoire de 46,1 % du PIB
là aussi un record aujourd'hui le
gouvernement Vals réduit sur le revenu
de 4 millions de foyers fiscaux il en
exclut 1,7 million alors que le
gouvernement précédent les y avait
introduit à la lecture du rapport de
Valérie rabau rapporteur général du
budget membre du Parti socialiste il est
clair qu'on ne réformme pas l'assiette
de l'impôt sur le revenu on ne fait
qu'appliquer un pansement exceptionnel
et non financé de façon
pérenne avec une prise de conscience
trop tardive vous prenez aujourd'hui des
mesures en faveur des entreprises
comprenant enfin que ce sont ell qui
créent l'emploi après avoir passé des
mois à les vilipander la TVA sociale
avait été l'objet de crétique virulente
avant riment partiel comprenant enfin là
aussi la nécessité de soutenir
l'appareil productif à ce sujet Quel est
le sort réservé aux conclusions des
quatre groupes de travail des Assises de
la fiscalité pertinemment rassemblé par
le Premier ministre héros en début
d'année il n'y a pas une trace dans
votre projet de
loi et ben écoutez je suis heureux que
vous corrigiez ce propos monsieur le
ministre vous comprendrez notre
déception monsieur le ministre nous
attendions beaucoup de ce collectif qui
conjointement avec le projet de loi de
financement rectificatif de la sécurité
sociale m en œuvre les premières mesures
du pacte de responsabilité et de
solidarité nouvelle feuille de route du
gouvernement ce pacte eû été un signal
fort allant dans le bon sens l'UDI était
prête à le soutenir mais sa mise en
œuvre est beaucoup trop poussive et la
déception est à la mesure de l'attente
forte très forte pourquoi faire un geste
aussi exceptionnel qu'improvisé sur
l'impôt sur le revenu alors que depuis
le mois de novembre de nombreux
parlementaires ont travaillé dans le
cadre des assis de la fiscalité un
projet de réforme pourquoi augmenter de
4 millions d'euros le plafond des
ressources affecté au Centre national du
spectacle vivant la liste serait encore
longue le texte qui nous est revenu de
l'Assemblée nationale est un inventaire
de cadeaux électoralistes sans vision
d'ensemble la Cour des comptes la
Commission européenne vous exhorte à des
réformes de structure repousser l'âge de
la retraite baisser le nombre de
fonctionnaires augmenter le temps du
travail effectif telle mesure certes
difficile et même parfois très difficile
avez-vous pris en ce sens les prévisions
de croissance et d'emploi sont
traditionnellement trop optimistes c'est
pour c'est pourquoi je renouvelle ma
proposition d'élaborer le budget sur une
prévision de croissance nulle ce qui
permet rait de réduire en euros constant
les dépenses du montant de l'inflation
et
de redonner ainsi sauf croissance
négative rarissime mécanique et de
réduire ainsi saufcroissance négative
rarissime mécaniquement des déficits je
tiens beaucoup à une réponse à cette
proposition monsieur le ministre vous
annoncez 50 milliards d'économie 2017 et
affirmer poursuivre l'assaainissement
des finances publiques en le fondant sur
les économies en dépenses ces 50
milliards d'économie reste très
mystérieux quant à leur
réalité quand prendrez-vous en compte
qu'il ne s'agit pas de modérer les
dépenses mais de les faire baisser elle
représente 57,4 de notre PIB soit 10
points de plus que la moyenne européenne
faut-il encore le rappeler les dépenses
publiques ont augmenté en France en 2013
alors qu'elles ont baissé dans le reste
de l'Europe c'est une réalité qui
devrait vous mobiliser et vous faire
prendre des mesures drastiques il
faudrait près de 17 milliards d'efforts
par an pour parvenir à l'objectif
annoncé à part les baisses de dépenses
si lié à diminution de la charge
d'intérêt de la dette qui dépendent des
marchés et la baisse des dotations aux
collectivités où sont les économies
quand mettrez-vous en application les
préconisations de la Cour des comptes
les injonctions de la Commission
européenne les conclusion de bon sens
des rapports de qualité que vous avez
commandé prendrez-vous exemple sur
l'action de pays dans une situation
comparable à la nôtre qui ont su
redresser leurs finances et se réformer
voyez la Grande-Bretagne voyez l'Italie
j'ai l'impression désagréable de répéter
les mêmes exhortations Vox clamentis
indéserto monsieur le ministre soit vous
laissez votre texte nêtre que le support
d'une vaste opération de communication
auquel cas nous voterons contre soit
nous pouvons faire de ce débat un lieu
de réforme que nous pourrions soutenir
tous ensemble à vous d'en décider
monsieur le
ministre merci la parole est à Monsieur
éc Boquet pour le groupe
CRC
tu vas bien
bien je en
profiter bien monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre chers
collègues à l'évidence l'examen de ce
projet de loi de finance rectificative
pour 2014 intervient dans un contexte
très particulier pour notre pays en
effet il n'est pas de débattre de ce
texte sans avoir en tête le doute
profond qui s'est emparé de l'ensemble
de nos concitoyens nous débattons ce
soir de la mise en œuvre du pacte de
responsabilité et de solidarité vous
venez de nous expliquer monsieur le
ministre qu'il convient de poursuivre et
amplifier les efforts car les efforts
payent nous dites-vous je doute que nos
concitoyens partagent votre enthousiasme
il y a quelques semaines deux rapports
ont été rendus public le premier par la
Cour des comptes et le second par le
Haut Conseil des finances pu publ si
ajoute début juin le verdict critique de
la Commission européenne sur le
programme français de stabilité pour les
années 2014 2017 des finances
publiques c'est moins le traditionnel
discours catastrophique sur la dette
publique portée par ces trois
institution qui doit retenir l'attention
que le constat commun de rentrée fiscale
moins bonne que prévu malgré les hausses
importantes d'impôt 6 semaines après le
séisme des élections européennes la
réalité impose son implacable vérité
plusieurs milliards d'euros manquent à
l'appel faute de croissance la politique
du gouvernement ne marche pas n'est-ce
pas le moment de rouvrir le débat à
escamooté au moment où a été prise la
décision de lancer le trop fameux pacte
de responsabilité à ce propos il est
intéressant de noter ici la déclaration
de l'ancien ministre des Finances
Monsieur Pierre Moscovici qui déclarait
sur un plateau de télévision au
lendemain de l'élection européenne je
cite le désendettement sans croissance
cela ne marche
plus propos jamais tenu par l'intéressé
ici dans cette enceinte moment
d'égarement liberté de parole recouvré
ou propos de campagne d'un candidat à la
fonction de commissaire européen qui
sait il n'empêche que ces paroles ne
manquent
d'interpeller le débat n'est donc pas
clos notre gouvernement s'entête dans
ses choix la priorité donnée à la
réduction des déficits provoque une
réduction de la croissance et
l'austérité imposée à tous les pays nous
conduit à l'échec je voudrais également
fait référence ici au propos de Madame
Valérie rabot notre collègue député
rapporteur du PLFR à l'Assemblée
nationale les mots que notre collègue a
prononcé sonne comme un véritable une
véritable mise en cause radicale de la
politique économique suivie par le
gouvernement je vais ici me permettre de
la citer selon les prévisions établies
par le ministère des Finances et des
comptes publics le plan d'économie de 50
milliards d'euros proposé par le
gouvernement pour la période 2015 à 2017
soit une réduction des dépenses de plus
de 2 points du PIB aurait ainsi un
impact négatif sur la croissance de 0,7
% par an en moyenne entre 2015 et 2017
et pourrait entraîner la suppression de
250000 emplois à à l'horizon 2017 fin de
citation ce constat n'est pas nouveau
depuis que la crise financière
économique a commencé en 2007 de
nombreux économistes alertent sur le
fait que la réduction à marche forcée
des déficits publics en Europe produit
un effet strictement opposé à celui qui
est officiellement escompté les plans
d'austérité mis en œuvre pour atteindre
cet objectif sappent toute possibilité
de rebond économique font le lit du
chômage et limitent les rentrées de
recettes fiscales ce qui donc creuse les
déficits que l'on était supposé
diminuer la dernière enquête publiée par
l'INC le 2 juillet dernier n'a
certainement pas manqué de vous
interpeller monsieur le ministre selon
l'institut les inégalités ont atteint
leur plus haut niveau enregistré depuis
1996 l'année 2011 fut parti
particulièrement faste pour les hauts
revenus tandis que la pauvreté touche
aujourd'hui 8,8 millions de personnes un
niveau historique savez-vous monsieur le
ministre que dans mon département du
Nord le Conseil Général dépense à chaque
minute qui passe 1100 € pour financer le
RSA socle oui chaque minute la
conséquence de l'explosion de cette
dépense de solidarité et la réduction
sensible de l'investissement du conseil
général pour la population du Nord ce
montant d'investissement passera l'an
prochain de 4 400 à 200 millions d'euros
et comme ce docteur difoirus cher à
Molière qui préconisait des saigner à
son malade déjà anémier vous réduisez
encore les dotations aux collectivités
dont chacun connaît très bien ici le
poids économique dans les territoires
mes chers collègues je ne voudrais pas
davantage noircir le tableau à l'extrême
mais le constat est là partagé sur tous
les bancs nos concitoyens souffre et
s'interroge pour l'immense majorité
d'entre eux il se désespère de la
politique il est est urgent et crucial
d'opérer une réorientation radicale de
vos choix
politiques le rapport de la commission
des finances présenté par notre
rapporteur général François Marc garde
une 11ce d'optimisme lorsqu'il indique
que pour la croissance de l'année en
cours je cite page 12 une prévision pour
2014 discuté mais qui demeure crédible
nous craignons pour notre part que trop
de voyant soit aujourd'hui au rouge pour
partager cette
prévision le président de la République
avait annoncé que le début du quinquena
serait une remise en ordre qui
permettrait ensuite une nouvelle
redistribution de la richesse à
l'évidence la feuille de route n'a eu
cour que le temps d'une campagne
électorale c'est un pari risqué sur le
plan social et économique mais aussi
politique oui les dépenses publique pèse
lourd dans notre pays qui osera ici
parler de gâie ne faut-il pas comme le
disent de nombreux économistes plus de
BI publics dans des sociétés de plus en
plus complexes et de plus en plus
fragiles nous combattons cette idée
selon laquelle il y aurait d'un côté des
acteurs privés producteurs de richesse
et de l'autre un état prédateur
irresponsable et
dépensier ce déficit qui est devenu
l'arme de destruction massive des
aspirations de nos concitoyens serait
uniquement le résultat de dépenses publi
excessive mais voyons un peu du côté des
recetes voyons l'évolution de la
situation ces dernières années l'État a
provoqué progressivement un déficit de
recette dans le budget avec les choix
d'exonération systématique des ménages
les plus aisés notamment et les grandes
entreprises la part des recettes de
l'État a diminué de 5 % du PIB en 30
années sur la même période la part des
dépenses publiques a chuté de deux
points de PIB si l'État au lieu de se
financer sur les marchés financiers
avait eu recours à des emprunts
directement auprès des ménages dont
l'épagne ne cessent de se consolider
tout au moins pour ceux qui on ont
encore la possibilité principe de
précaution oblige ou bien des banques
pratiquant un taux d'intérêt réel de 2
pour la dette publique serait
aujourd'hui inférieure à 29 % du PIB
soit environ 600 milliards d'euros notre
groupe vous l'avez bien compris et dans
des accords complets avec la philosophie
générale de ce projet de loi de finance
rectificative vous voulez réduire le
coût du travail je mets à titre
personnel des guillemets autour de cette
expression pièce maîtresse des éléments
de langage fabriqués dans l'arsenal
d'une certaintaine idéologie car nous
avons la faiblesse de penser que le
travail n'est pas un coût mais facteur
de richesse nous sommes étouffés par le
carcan de la règle d'or étouffés par la
rigueur budgétaire tous les ministères
seront
touchés il y a eu grande communication
autour de la baisse d'impôts pour des
catégories de contribuables modestes
présenté comme une bonne nouvelle certes
mais ne convient-il pas de rapporter
cette somme de 1,16 milliards d'euros
auquel que 6 milliards de TVA
supplémentaires que la hausse des taux
au 1er janvier 2014 a pu générer donnez
d'une main ce que vous avez déjà repris
de l'autre nous nous félicitons durant
renforcement du contrôle des prix de
transfert notamment en cas de transfert
vers les paradis fiscaux très bien mais
la liste française des paradis fiscau
prévoit-elle de réintégrer Jersey et les
Bermudes qui en furent retiré de manière
tout à fait incompréhensible en janvier
de cette année oui il faut pousser
activement les feux de l'échange
automatique d'information en matière
fiscale c'est un enjeu d'avenir il
faudra beaucoup de volonté et
d'engagement et ne pas croire ou laisser
croire que le seul retour des exilés
repenti vers si afin de régulariser leur
situation suffira à éradiquer ce
scandale de l'évasion fiscale c'est
toute une machinerie une industrie qu'il
faudra démanteler afin d'espérer
récupérer un jour les dizaines de
milliards d'euros qui manquent au budget
de la République il nous faut aussi
pousser les feux de la transparence
totale sans dérogation c'est bien l'une
des conditions de la réussite de cette
bataille à livrer pour la justice
fiscale notre groupe défendra donc ces
amendements visant à un véritable
changement de logique ils porteront sur
le barême de l'impôt sur l'impôt de
solidarité sur la fortune dont nous
avons pu observer au passage que le
rendement 2013 était supérieur de 10 %
au prévisions alors même que le nombre
d'assujétis avait été réduit de 300000
personnes c'estd les possibilités de
ressources qui existent de ce côté-là
pas de dogmatisme beaucoup de
pragmatisme monsieur le ministre
l'argument essentiel de vos choix
consiste en un nouvel allègement
conséquent pour les entreprises en ce
jour d'ouverture de la conférence
sociale dont on peut dire qu'à
l'évidence elle ne fédère pas l'ensemble
des acteurs sociaux de ce pays ainsi
nous apprenons aujourd'hui que deux
organisations syndicales majeur ont pris
la décision de ne pas participer aux TBL
ronde de demain cette conférence sociale
troè du nom est quasiment mornée depuis
deux décennies depuis le gouvernement
baladure en 2002 ce sont des dizaines de
milliards d'euros d'allègement
exonération diverses qui ont été accordé
pour quel bilan vous nous avez dit
Monsieur le Ministre poursuivre et
amplifier les efforts a-t-on procédé à
la moindre évaluation de l'efficacité de
ces aides je note avec intérêt
l'objectif de création d'un observatoire
des contreparties cela manque
singulièrement aujourd'hui je voudrais à
ce propos anticiper un peu sur le
rapport de la mission d'information
menée par no collègu Charles Genet comme
président et mon ami Michel de Messine
sénatrice du Nord comme rapporteur sans
déflorer le contenu du rapport qui sera
rendu public la semaine prochaine je me
permettrai ici d'en évoquer d'ors et
déjà un constat assez
édifiant l'efficacité des exonérations
de charges en matière d'emploi n'est
absolument pas démontrée plus on entre
dans le détail plus on doute et constate
les dérives cette importante dépense
publique est bâtie uniquement sur le
dogme du coût du travail elle nécessite
une réelle évaluation qui fait défaut
aujourd'hui malgré laabon temp de
littérature sur le sujet et l'empilement
des rapports on est incapable de faire
la différence entre les emplois créés
les emplois sauvegardés et on ne s'est
pas donneré de fourchette plus précise
que de parler de 70000 à 800000 emplois
créés ainsi le constat est-il fait que
les secteurs non exposés à la
concurrence étrangère internationale
comme la grande distribution bénéficient
aussi de cette avantage plus grave
encore on tire les salaires vers le bas
sans conteste ce rapport d'information
constituera une mine d'information
essentielle pour cet observatoire des
contreparties ne nous privons pas de
cette nouvelle et belle contribution du
Sénat à la réflexion collective il doit
rester dans les armoires du MDF un
certain nombre de millions de pins qui
arborit fierement le slogan 1 million
d'emplois il y a quelques mois chiche
monsieur gataz monsieur le ministre ce
budget en l'état ne peut recueillir
l'accord du groupe communiste
républicains et citoyens nous pousserons
le débat le plus loin possible pour
infléchir vos choix nous sommes
convaincus que la situation économique
sociale et politique l'exige il y va y
compris de l'équilibre de notre société
je vous remercie
merci la parole est à monsieur Yvon
Collin pour le groupe
RDSE monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous
examinons cette année à mchemin dans
l'exécution budgétaire un projet de loi
de finan rectificative qui
avec le projet de loi de financement
rectificatif de la sécurité sociale que
nous examinerons dans les prochains
jours le premier vecteur législatif du
pacte de responsabilité et de
solidarité ce texte comporter monsieur
le ministre initialement outre l'article
liminaire dont il sera question tout à
l'heure six articles dont l'article
premier sans doute le plus important qui
procède aux allègements d'impôts sur le
revenu en faveur des ménages modestes et
c'est une mesure de justice fiscale à
laquelle nous sommes au groupe
particulièrement attachés quant aux
entreprises ce texte ne leurit à
première vue guerre favorable puisque le
principal article les concernant
l'article 5 prolonge en réalité deant la
surtaxe de l'impôt sur les sociétés
versé par les plus grandes d'entre elles
certes il faut voir cela dans une
stratégie d'ensemble j'entends bien le
gouvernement a déjà mis en place la
banque publique d'investissement ainsi
que le crédit d'impôt compétitivité le
cice qui est un
outil simple efficace plébiscité par les
entreprises par ailleurs dans le cadre
du pacte de responsabilité solidarité
des allégements très conséquents de
cotisation sociale pour les employeurs
et pour les salariés ainsi que pour les
travailleurs indépendants sont prévus et
seront actés dans la loi de financement
rectificatif de la sécurité sociale pour
2014 ensuite à compter de
2017 une baisse du taux d'impôt sur les
sociétés il est il faut bien le dire
monsieur le ministre exceptionnellement
élevé dans notre pays sera engagé pour
atteindre 28 % en
2020 ces mesures monsieur le ministre
sont attendues elles permettront aux
entreprises de restaurer leur Marg et
d'investir pour renforcer leur
compétitivité et Infiné nous l'espérons
créer plus d'emplois personnellement je
m'en réjouis mais je souhaiterais tout
de même souligner que nous ne pouvons
pas agir uniquement sur les facteurs de
compétitivité coûte et en particulier
sur le coût du
travail nos entreprises doivent aussi et
je dirais surtout se différencier par
des facteurs de compétitivité hors coûte
comme l'innovation comme la qualité et
c'est d'ailleurs l'esprit de la fameuse
montée en gamme que Louis Galois appelé
de ses vœux dans son Excell rapport de
novembre 2012 c'est une étape
supplémentaire à franchir qui doit être
encouragée par les pouvoirs publics mais
monsieur le ministre de C article à
l'origine ce texte est passé à 36
articles un ayant été supprimé et 30
nouveaux adoptés par l'Assemblée
nationale je sais qu'il s'agit souvent
dans les textes de cette nature de
prendre un certain nombre de mesure de
correction et voire d'adaptation mais
cela ne devrait pas empêcher une
cohérence d'ensemble qui fait me
semble-t-il cruellement défaut dans le
cas
présent ainsi avec une
certaines précipitation l'Assemblée
nationale a adopté des mesures très
disparates qui peuvent même sembler à
certains égards contradictoire si bien
qu'on a du mal parfois à comprendre le
sens de ce
collectif certaines dispositions ont été
jusqu'à créer des dissensions au au sein
même du gouvernement faute d'arbitrage
interministériel je pense bien sûr aux
articles qui poent sur la taxe de séjour
et dont notre rapporteur général nous
propose il a sans doute raison de
repousser l'entrée en vigueur tant ils
apparaissent précipités mais aussi mal
calibrés voilà bonjour et bienvenue sur
les chaînes parlementaire nous
interrompons cette séance de discussion
budgétaire pour rejoindre le Conseil
économique social et environnemental qui
accueille aujourd'hui